so here this is a really quite unusual
sample from Goodfellow and you see this
is samarium so this is one of the
lanthanides okay so Sumeria is a
beautiful element to work with because
it can change and what we refer to as
oxidation states very easily which gives
it many more things that you can do in
chemistry it's also a fascinating
element in the sense that we can use it
to date samples from the moon so this is
a sample of samarium and there's a very
small amount of it here perhaps half of
a gram but you know there's some
interesting things that we can see about
this package because you can see on this
label it says packed in argon handle
with care now it's packed in argon
because our gun is very very inert it
doesn't react with anything so it's used
to store safely this sample so that we
can get it to carry out research but I
think that this sample as perhaps become
damaged because I think the package may
be broken because the samarium is gone
and all you can see now inside is this
white packet white powder which I
suspect is samarium oxide so
unfortunately not elemental samarium but
close smelling is also very important
because it's a neutron absorber which
means it's got a lot of use in nuclear
power stations basically to stop them
going boom